DANIEL VIVEIROS: Hey, guys.
Good morning.
Thank you very much
for being here.
My name is Daniel.
And I'm here today to
tell a story to you.
A story of how we went
from idea to market
in less than six months.
I'm here to share our experience
on creating new products
with Google Cloud Platform.
I have been working with
Google Cloud Platform for more
than five years, right now.
I'm a Google Developer
expert, by the way.
But my main job is being the
head of Product Engineering
at CI&T. CI&T is a Brazilian
company with subsidiaries
in Japan, China, Europe, Canada,
and the United States, as well.
We have a lot of
talented people.
And we are really proud to
be elected the Google Cloud
partner of the year into 2014.
We got this
recognition last year.
And part of this
recognition came from cases
like this one here, the
Coca-Cola Happiness Flag.
You saw the video today
at the keynote, right?
Coca-Cola Happiness Flag
is a global market campaign
from Coca-Cola to
FIFA World Cup 2014.
The campaign was the World
Cup is for everybody.
And the idea was to connect
people all around the world,
getting photos to create
this huge photo mosaic called
the Happiness Flag.
We created a system
that engaged the users
on social networks such as
Facebook, Twitter, Instagram.
We created websites to allow
users to submit photos directly
to Coca-Cola.
We converted text to image.
We did a lot of things.
And at the end of the campaign,
we had millions of images.
We did everything using
Google App Engine.
For computer workloads, we
stored this massive amount
of images on Google
Cloud Storage.
And we used Google Compute
Engine for specific workloads,
such as advanced
image transformations.
And the result is here.
The Happiness Flag was unveiled
during the opening of the World
Cup.
And the overall campaign
was a huge success.
At this point, we felt we had
a very special set of skills.
We had this strong
partnership with Google.
We had great developers-- a lot
of Google certified developers,
by the way.
We had been working with
machine learning for a while.
And we had always been
heavy users of Google Apps
and Google+.
We knew we could do
something remarkable
with this special set of skills.
And we did our company website.
Sounds a little bit
frustrating, right?
Well, not actually.
Our company website is
a very cool website.
It's a card based website.
Very responsive.
It renders in different
kinds of displays.
It is social connected, so it's
really easy to get a post from
Google+, for example, and
leverage that post inside
our website.
And it's the smart.
We are using machine learning
and recommendation systems
to provide a custom
experience for our users.
We are putting what is
more relevant on the top
and what is less
relevant on the bottom.
Actually, our
website was so cool
that our customers wanted it.
And we started a new line of
business based on our website.
Today, we have our
website running
on more than 25 companies,
including very large ones.
We were excited,
but we still thought
that we had zero product.
That's because
every time we needed
to deploy a new
version of our website,
we were still taking
from one to three months
to do that because we need
to do a lot of customizations
in terms of look and feel, a lot
of discussions with marketing
areas, if card is a good
design strategy or not.
We need to handle
feature requests.
And we wanted a very,
very scalable product
in terms of business.
We wanted a software
as a service product.
We wanted to move
from 0 to 1 product.
That's why September, 2015,
we ran a design sprint.
A design sprint is a
methodology from Google
that allows you to move from
idea, discuss this idea,
prototype this idea, and
validate this idea with users.
And we did everything.
We did everything by the book.
We got a lot of people
inside another home.
And we converged.
We diverged.
We prototyped ideas.
And we validated those
ideas with users,
customers, prospects.
And at the end of
this period, we
had the vision of
our first product.
And we called it Smart Canvas.
And I want to share this
vision with you, right now.
Smart Canvas is a system that
allows you to tear down silos,
to connect people.
And we want to do that
in a very smart way.
So we allow our users--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-To inspire more
and more knowledge,
and ignite night great ideas.
What if connections could
be made automatically
to propel the most
important thing,
to bring people closer together,
to heighten ideas and solve
problems, together.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
DANIEL VIVEIROS: Of
course, at that point,
we just had the idea.
The video came later.
So now, we had the idea.
We just need to
build the product.
And that's the story I want
to tell you, right now.
And to help me tell the story, I
want to introduce you our gang.
They usually help us
with announcements,
with customer support.
Today, they agreed to help me
with this presentation, here.
We are going to do a
little role playing game.
So let me introduce you.
First is Lorenzo.
Lorenzo if from Italy.
Very sophisticated.
He's going to be our UX Expert.
We have Olivia.
Olivia is from Australia.
She's very tough.
She's going to be
our Scrum Master.
We have Ajay from
Jamaica-- addicted
on Android technologies.
He's going to be our
Mobile Developer.
We have Liam.
Liam is from the United States.
He loves Chrome,
Polymer, AngularJS,
all the web technologies.
He's going to be our
Frontend Developer.
And we have Tania Tanya's
from Brazil, Rio de Janeiro
She likes Samba.
And she is a nerd.
Yes, it's possible.
Tania's one of those people.
I'm the second one.
I don't know if we have more.
There's just one person
missing, our Hound.
Our grumping-- I mean
lovable, Product Manager.
And Apollo agreed to play
our Product Manager, today.
And he is the first one to
say, OK, we have a deadline.
We needed to get
the product done
by the event, TeamWork 2016.
The event TeamWork 2016
is a huge Google event
that just happened in
Las Vegas two weeks ago.
And Google partners
all around the world
came to Vegas to know the
roadmap, to talk with Googlers,
to network with other partners.
And it was very important.
It was a really good
opportunity for us
to introduce Smart
Canvas in this event
because we could
get some customers,
perhaps some reselling
opportunities,
but for sure, we will be able
to get valuable feedback.
Smart Canvas was designed
since the very beginning
to work very tightly
coupled with Google Apps.
Seamless experience
with Google Apps.
So being able to show Smart
Canvas to those partners
was really a big thing for us.
That's why we needed to
move from idea to market
in less than six months.
We needed to hit
the ground running.
And when it comes to
hit the ground running,
I like using Google App Engine.
I know that for most of you,
using Google Compute Engine,
using infrastructure
as a service would
be the first choice.
For me, it would be
to the third choice.
I would like to go with
Google App Engine first.
Second would be
Container Engine-- using
containers deployed on Google.
And the third one,
Compute Engine.
I like Google App Engine,
not only because it provides
fully abstraction
of infrastructure,
so we don't have
to worry about load
balancing, high availability,
stuff like that,
but also because it provides
an architecture for you
to develop.
It provides a mechanism, such
as Memcache, task queues.
So it's very handy when you
need to hit the ground running.
We used Google App
Engine for Coca-Cola.
Engine for our website.
We had the expertise.
So now, we decided to
use App Engine again.
So Olivia told the
team, guys, we are
going to use Google App Engine.
And that triggered
some reactions, right?
Some people were not very
happy with that decision.
Oh, my god.
Is it really flexible?
I don't know.
I'm afraid of death.
Some people were willing
to use containers.
So, what?
You're not going
to use containers?
Are you sure of that?
But we got some very
important support
from our senior developers.
Thank you very much
for the support.
And we decided to go
with Google App Engine.
In terms of user
interface, Lorenzo
asked us to use Material Design.
Material Design is a
no-brainer decision
when you are talking about
Android Development, rights?
So Ajay was really happy
with that decision.
Not that common when you are
talking about web development.
You don't see a lot of
websites using Material Design,
right now.
But Polymer has just gotten 1.0.
And we were excited
with the great website
that Google did for
Google I/O 2015.
So we decided to use Polymer.
And we decided to use Material
Design on all platforms.
Well, the backend developers--
they couldn't care less.
So that's the first
architecture we got.
Very simple.
We had the frontend here.
We had the web using Polymer.
We had Android.
We had iOS.
All the clients
consuming services
served by Google App Engine.
We are using Google Datastore
for storing business data.
Again, we could use
Cloud SQL, for example.
But we decided to use the
simplest technology, which
is Datastore.
And we are also using
Google Cloud Storage
for storing large files,
such as images for example.
And with just that
architecture here,
with just these
components, we were
able to allow our users to
create knowledge, compose
new posts, or bring knowledge
to the product sharing
external articles,
or bringing Google
documents to the product.
We have this amazing
integration with Google Drive.
We were able to allow our
users to see everything
in a timeline, in a
chronological order are just
what is targeted [INAUDIBLE]
in the [INAUDIBLE] channel.
We allowed our users to create
boards, topics of interest--
very similar to what Pinterest
does, into to curate content
inside the boards.
And we allowed them
to share everything
with other people and
other teams, everything
just using these
components here.
I'm going to tell
you a little secret.
I'm going to be 100%
honest with you.
These screenshots you
just saw, they were not
from the first release.
They are the current
release, right now.
We polished these screenshots.
We polished our user
interface over time.
And that was possible
because we saved time
using Google App Engine.
And that's the value that Google
App Engine brings to the table.
You can start coding right away.
You can deliver the first
very versions really fast.
And you can tweak,
and you can change,
and you can get those feedbacks
and react to them accordingly.
So we were up and running.
Let's talk about search.
We needed to have a
very, very good search.
That makes a lot of sense
because the idea for Smart
Canvas was to collect as
much content as possible,
either create it inside Smart
Canvas or external content.
So we would need a
very powerful way
to allow our users to search
for that content later.
The first choice here would
be using Google Search API.
We used Google Search
API for our website.
And the results were good.
But now, we decided
to use Elasticsearch
because it's more flexible
and, in our opinion,
it's more powerful.
The problem here is that you
cannot deploy Elasticsearch
on Google App Engine.
Actually, you cannot even access
Elasticsearch using Google App
Engine.
Hah.
Yeah.
Told me Ajay.
Again, Tania, thank you
very much for the support.
We can always increase
complexity as needed.
We can expand our
architecture to accommodate
specific workloads.
You need to be
aware, whenever you
decide to use a platform
or a fully managed service,
at some point you may need to
create a specific microservice
to handle specific workloads.
And that's what we did.
We used Cloud Launcher to
provision some service,
with Elasticsearch.
It's very handy because,
with a few clicks,
you can have the
service up and running.
So you should consider that,
at least for the development
and [INAUDIBLE] environments.
For production
environments, you may
need a more tuned
environment so you
can create your own recipes.
But at least for the development
and [INAUDIBLE] environments,
you should go with
Cloud Launcher.
And we created the
Search microservice.
So now, every search
request that comes
from the client to our core,
the core forwards that request
to the Search microservice.
We are using Compute
Engine for that.
We Get the response.
And send it back to the clients.
Now, we need to
index the content.
We could use the same approach.
Whenever a new post is
created inside Smart Canvas,
we could just send
that information so
Elasticsearch, for example,
and let it index the content.
We decided to do a
different approach.
We created an event
broker using Pub-Sub.
And it pays off.
I'm going to show
you how we are going
to expand this idea of
using Pub-Sub, here.
So whenever something meaningful
happens inside the core,
a new post is created,
a new comment,
a user just liked
a specific post.
We get this event and send
that event to Pub-Sub.
And Pub-Sub takes care of
distributing this event
to several microservices.
Right now, we just
have Search, here,
but you are going to see
how we evolved this idea.
With that, we were able to
create a very nice search.
I love the way
that Elasticsearch
deals with relevance.
And not only that, we
were able to create
cool features, such
as autocomplete,
for example, helping
our customers
to ask for the right questions.
So now, our users are
also able to search
for content, for boards, and for
teams with this architecture,
here.
We are now up and running, and
we have the powerful search.
Another request.
Social.
Everything's social, right now.
People don't like to
feel that they are alone.
We live in a social world.
We are so used
with applications,
with app such as Facebook,
Twitter, WhatsApp, Google+,
whatever.
We knew from the very
beginning that Smart Canvas
should be social, as well.
Lorenzo raised the
bar a little bit.
OK, I want social, but
I also want real-time.
So we did some basic stuff.
For example, we
created notifications
with a live counter to show
many notifications you have.
We allowed our users to like,
to pin, to bookmark a post,
also with counters.
We have comments, but
we are showing a toast,
saying, OK, there is a
new comment available.
Do you like to comment,
anyway, or do you
like to see that comment first?
That's the kind of real-time
thing I was talking about.
And we did something that we
consider very special, which
is, we show on the top of
the post who else is seeing
the same post as you are,
right now, in the same fashion
that google docs does with
documents, presentations,
spreadsheets, and so on.
We used Firebase for that.
Jake came with that idea
and I couldn't agree more.
I had always been a
huge fan of Firebase.
And I was really happy when
Google acquired the company
two years ago.
And we brought Firebase
to our architecture.
Let me show how we did that.
First, we created another
microservice called
the real-time microservice.
This time, we are not
using Compute Engine.
We are using just another
module inside App Engine.
Why?
Because it's simpler to do that.
We had no reason to use
Compute Engine here.
And now, Pub-Sub not
only sends all the events
to Search s microservice,
but it also sends the events
to the Real-time microservice.
With that, we can
just, for example,
send that information to GCM,
to Google Cloud Messaging,
so our mobile
users can have push
notifications on their devices.
And we can send that
information to Firebase.
And it's so simple to do that.
With very few lines of code--
three lines of code, here.
This example is using
Java with Jersey.
But I'm pretty sure that any
language of your preference
would be as simple as that.
We can store data
inside Firebase.
What is happening
behind the scenes here--
we are building a data tree.
So here's example.
We have tenants because we
are a multi-tenant solution.
We have CI&T. It's our tenant.
We have posts.
We have the number of likes.
The number of notifications.
Everything.
You just need to model
that information using
Firebase's best practices.
Here's another example
for the presence alert
I mentioned before.
That's how to show who
else is seeing the post.
Very simple.
Very straightforward.
Now, we need to consume that
information to get these events
and react to them
in the frontend.
And it's very simple to do
because Firebase provides
SDKs for JavaScript,
provides SDKs Android,
provides SDKs for iOS.
So we just need to do
to create the callback
and react to them accordingly.
One example, here.
If you want to do the something
similar of what it did,
show the avatar
of another person
that is reading the same
post as you are, right now.
You just need to write a
few lines of JavaScript.
Here, I'm listening to the
onValue value event, which
is going to be triggered
every time information
changes in the data tree.
And you just need
to keep a few lists
and show the icon on
the top of the page.
Very simple, right?
So that's Firebase.
And now, we are also
social and dynamic.
The core business, the
secret sauce of Smart Canvas
has always been to tear down
silos, to connect people
with content in a smarter way.
So now, it's time to be smart.
And that's my favorite part.
We want to be smart.
We want to be magical.
We want to impact our users.
And make them think, oh, my god.
How do they know that?
The same way Google has
always been doing with us.
Let me try to explain with you
the initial idea which we think
is very simple,
yet very powerful.
We wanted to build
this graph, here.
And we wanted to build
it automatically.
So for example, if
I have a person,
I want to know what are
the topics of interest
for that person.
And I also want to know what
are the most recommended content
for that specific person.
If I have a topic,
I want to know who
are the experts of that topic.
And also, what are the
contents more relevant
for this specific topic.
Given the content,
I want to know
what are the topics
for that content
and who are the
people that would
be interested in that content.
So if you would be able
to create this graph
and master all
these relationships,
we knew that we could build
something remarkable, something
very, very interesting.
So we created the Machine
Learning microservice.
So whenever the core needs
to get some insights to amaze
the user, it just sends a
request to the Machine Learning
microservice.
And we also have some data being
exchanged between the Machine
Learning and the Pub-Sub.
But let's drill sound a little
bit in this Machine Learning
microservice.
We have App Engine
integrating with Pub-Sub
and Pub-Sub distributing
all day events--
a new post, a new comment, a
new link shared, a new board.
Whatever happens
inside Smart Canvas,
Pub-Sub is aware of that.
So now, we are sending all
that information to BigQuery
as well.
And we are creating this
huge TouchPoint database
with everything that
happens inside Smart Canvas.
Actually, pretty much the same
approach that Spotify is doing.
We just saw it here
in this morning.
Now, we need to read data
and crunch that information
to get these insights.
And we're using
Dataproc for that.
Dataproc is a fully
managed service
from Google that allows you to
run Hadoop and Spark processes.
And we are using Pi Spark,
to be more specific,
because we have our
own machine learning
algorithms written in Python.
So we are running
everything inside Dataproc.
And whenever we
have the insights,
we are writing it on
a Cassandra database.
We could use Cloud SQL.
We could use Datastore if you
want to know, for example, oh,
my god what are
the topics related
to that person, for
example, or, what
are the contents for
that specific person.
If it's something
really simple, we
could use Cloud
SQL or Datastore.
But we decided to use
Titan, a graph database that
runs on the top of
Cassandra because it's
way more flexible to
run queries on a graph.
So we can run multiple nodes.
And it's really,
really powerful.
So whenever I want to get an
insight to show to my customer,
App Engine sends a
request to Titan.
And Titan reads the data
and gets that information
to App Engine.
But not only that, we are
pushing that information back
to Pub-Sub.
And Pub-Sub can send
that information
to our search microservice.
That's really nice because,
now, when a person searches
for Google, for
example, he's going
to have content with the
Google keyword on it.
He's going to have
boards, themes.
But he also will get person
who is interested in Google.
He is going to get the experts
of this specific topic.
Think about your HR area.
They want to know, for example,
who inside their company
knows Angular.js or Node.js.
They can search for
it and can know--
can get the results of the
persons who are talking
about that specific subject.
That's the best way to do
knowledge management because it
doesn't becomes obsolete.
So here are some real examples.
Here's my profile
inside Smart Canvas.
I put in some information.
I said that I like
cloud computing, Google,
Smart Canvas.
But the algorithms
also discovered
that I'm interested in
Cloud Platform, nuvem,
which is cloud in Portuguese.
And poker, I was in
Vegas two weeks ago.
People related to you.
People who are talking
about the same things
that you are right now.
So I'm in Brazil.
I'm interested in Google.
I may have a coworker
in China that's
also interested in Google.
Why not put us in contact.
That's what we mean
by tear down silos.
by connect people.
And we can have this
vision also per topic.
So for example, because
I'm interested in Google,
we have some people
related to you.
Because you are
interested in digital,
we have some people
related to you.
And we also have a channel
that we call Discover that
shows posts relevant for you.
So because you like Cloud,
there is brand new information
here for you.
Because you are reading about
Google, about Material Design,
I have some posts
for you, as well.
That's the best way to be
updated what's going on
inside your organization.
So that's machine learning.
And now, we are also smart.
The cherry on the
top of the cake.
We had our web application.
We have some mobile apps.
We could access those
to get information.
But now, we want to make the
information find the person.
We want to cast content
from Smart Canvas
to external displays.
We want to explore.
We want to innovate on
top of Smart Canvas.
And that's where
Pub-Sub pays off.
It's very, very simple
to create experiments
using Pub-Sub because
you just create
another few subscriptions.
And you can get all the
data, all the events,
and do whatever
you want with that.
And it's so simple that
just one developer is
able to do that in a few days.
So Liam took care
of that for us.
We just created what
we call Co-Cast,
another microservice add-on.
Whatever you want to call it.
And here it is.
Whenever a new post is
created inside Smart Canvas,
the information goes to Pub-Sub.
Pub-Sub sends that information
to the add-on, to Co-Cast.
And Co-Cast takes care of
showing that information
in a television.
Today, at CN&T, we have
several televisions
showing what's going on
inside our Smart Canvas.
We used Container
Engine for that.
Just for fun.
Actually, just for fun, we think
that Container is a very, very
strategic technology.
I personally see, in the
near future-- I don't know,
few months or a few years--
great chunk of Smart Canvas
running inside Containers.
So trying to explore, trying
to get to know the container's
technology right now-- it seems
to be a good opportunity for us
to get these [INAUDIBLE]
necessary to works
with containers.
So we did that on
Container Engine.
Just another example.
We decided to
integrate with Slack.
Slack is getting momentum--
not getting momentum.
He has already gotten it.
So whenever you create a new
post inside Smart Canvas,
you have this post
coming to Slack, as well.
So that's it.
So now we are Smart, magical.
But we also explore
and innovate.
And here are the results.
We went to Las Vegas
a couple of weeks ago.
We had the opportunity to
talk about Smart Canvas
with partners, with
customers, with Googlers.
We had the opportunity to
talk about it on stage.
And we got another recognition.
We were elected the
Most Googley Partner
of the year, which
means that we are
really committed to
Google, to Material Design,
to all Google technologies.
We are Alpha Testers.
We are Beta Testers.
We strongly believe in GCP.
And that's [INAUDIBLE].
Just recapping, we
are up and running.
Use the fully managed services.
Use Google API Engine.
Start simple and increase
complexity as needed.
Whenever you want
increased complexity.
That's what we did with search.
You can always
create a microservice
to handle specific workloads.
Be social.
Be dynamic.
But also be real-time.
We have Firebase for that.
Be Smart.
Be magical.
We have several offerings
from Google, right now.
We have Cloud Machine Learning.
You just saw it.
Cloud Vision.
We are working with that.
We are playing with
that, right now, as well.
You can create your own
machine learning algorithms
using the whole set
of big data tools
that Google offers to you.
And explore.
Innovate.
Create great things,
amazing things,
the next things using
the Google technologies.
We are in private
beta, right now.
If you go to
smartcanvas.com, you
can submit your interest
in trying Smart Canvas
and I will be more than happy
to whitelist your domain.
I will be around to answer
questions, if you want to.
And that's it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]